This video is brought to you by Swedish pod one Oh one pod one Oh one courses
are one of my favorite ways to start learning a new language online,
click the link in the description for a free lifetime account to give it a try.
Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul. Today.
We're going to focus on the Swedish language. The
[inaudible] in Swedish or adjust civilians.
Swedish has spoken by around 10 million people, mainly in Sweden,
where it's the native language of around 8 million people.
And also in Finland where it's the second official language after finished with
around 270,000 native speakers.
It's a continental North dramatic language,
which is closely related to Norwegian and Danish,
and is mutually intelligible with them to some extent the degree,
depending on the dialects in question like all North dramatic languages.
Swedish is at the ascendance of old Norse,
which developed from prodo Germanic by the eighth century over the next 600
years or so old North developed into the various North dramatic languages of
today, old North first diverged into old West North in Norway,
Iceland, and the Faroe islands and oldest North's in Sweden and Denmark.
All these snores then divided into old Danish and old Swedish by around the 13th
century. All these North is sometimes referred to as runic,
Swedish and runic Danish,
even though they were basically the same until around the year 1100.
This name comes from the fact that it was written in the runic alphabet,
specifically the younger Fouth Ark alphabet,
the Latin alphabet was adopted in Sweden around 1225 due to the
Christianization of Sweden.
And this marks the beginning of the old Swedish period later that century,
the Hanseatic league began to arise.
It was an Alliance of middle low German speaking trade communities spread out
across the Baltic region and Scandinavia,
including the major cities of Sweden through its domination of trade over the
next several centuries.
And through the settlement of aristocratic families from what is now Northern
Germany,
middle low German had a significant impact on the vocabulary of Swedish.
Swedish also became simpler in its grammar,
as it developed from old Swedish to modern Swedish.
It originally had a more complex case system for cases rather than the current
two cases, three genders,
rather than the current two genders and the more complex verb system,
the printing press and the publishing of a Swedish Bible in the 16th century,
the Gustaf Vasa Bible marked the beginning of the modern Swedish period.
The Gustaf Vasa Bible was a major step towards more standardized orthography,
but it wasn't until the 19th and 20th centuries that Swedish became more uniform
due to migration and urbanization.
And a standard language was created by the time of the spelling reform of
1906. Swedish was almost the same as the contemporary Swedish in use today.
Today. Standard Swedish dominates throughout Sweden in general,
and most people are fluent. It regional dialects are still widely spoken though.
They are not quite as distinct as they once were because of the influence of
standard Swedish. The main dialectal difference today lies in accent.
Let's examine some of the features of Swedish focusing on standard Swedish.
There are 29 letters in the Swedish alphabet, nine of them,
vowel letters and 20 of them consonant letters.
But those letters represent more than 29 distinct phonemes.
The vowel letters represent pairs of short vowels and long vowels with short
vowels appearing before a long continent.
That means two or more consonants and long vowels appearing before a short
continent, meaning a single continent or before a vowel or at the end of a word.
In most cases, the long and short vowels are also different in quality,
not only length, for example,
this word has a long vowel in loss and it means a glass.
This word has a short, a vowel plus, and it means ice cream.
This word has a long vowel BU and it means cure.
This word has a short vowel boots and it means stayed
standard. Swedish has no phonemic diphthongs though.
Some dialects such as the Scania and dialects of Southern Sweden,
do some consonant sounds are represented by diagraphs.
These diagraphs all represent the sound year as does the letter J as well
as G before front vowels.
These diagraphs all represent the sound as it does S K before front
vowels. Otherwise it's pronounced sky.
These diagraphs represent sure as does K before front vowels.
Otherwise it's pronounced cut. And sometimes C H, which is used in loan words.
This diagraph represents Ghana at the beginning of words,
and no in other contexts,
this diagraph represents no or [inaudible].
And these diagraphs represent retroflex consonants.
The retroflex element being shown by the R in each diagraph.
The standard sound represented by R is a voiced alveolar trill,
and at some words and alveolar tap,
but this is one sound that differs depending on the dialect with some Southern
dialects of Swedish,
pronouncing it as a uvular trill or as a voiceless or a voice to uvular
fricative the letter G is normally either pronounced like a hard G
or yeah, before front vowels.
It's never pronounced just like the soft G in English like Norwegian.
Swedish has pitch accent, a shift in tone on the stressed syllable,
like in Norwegian, there are two tone patterns. Tone. One is a rising tone.
The pitch rises on the stressed syllable then falls on the unstressed syllable
that follows tone. Two is a falling rising, falling tone.
The pitch falls on the stressed syllable then rises and falls again on the
unstressed syllable that follows many pairs of words can be distinguished based
on their pitch accent. Here's an example in tone one, Ooh, gala,
meaning the book and.
In tone to bull gum, meaning.
Overripe or spoiled regarding fruit tone to normally appears in words
with multiple syllables and inflection. Aside from the definite article tone,
one normally appears in words with only one syllable and words with the definite
article attached,
the N in book-in is a definite article.
Dulles, the boot Dylan. This means I.
Read the book word for word it's. I read book,
the Swedish word order is SVO as an English.
The only difference here being the placement of the definite article,
the definite article, it takes the form of a suffix in Swedish,
and it's formed depends on the gender and number of the now modern Swedish,
at least in its standard form has two genders,
common gender and neutral gender for singular common gender announced.
The definite article is usually N or after a vowel oo gala.
The definite article for singular neuter nouns is at or.
To stilette. However.
The final T is usually silent in most accents.
Unlike the definite article,
the indefinite article comes before the now and for common announce and
BU and at for neuter notes.
How about for plural nouns?
Indefinite plural nouns are formed by adding indefinite suffixes,
which differ depending on the nouns ending.
Book, good books, still alum.
Leases for plural definite nouns in the common gender.
You add NA to the indefinite plural.
The books for plural.
Definite nouns in the neutral gender. You add on to those ending in a vowel,
and you add N to those ending in a continent, Stella, the places.
[Inaudible]. This.
Means he doesn't drink coffee word for word it's he drink not coffee.
Again, this sentence is SVO with one difference from English syntax,
the negation marker in that comes after the verb, rather than before it.
And also notice that well, English has the auxiliary verb do here in the form.
Doesn't Swedish has no equivalent of that. If we make the sentence affirmative,
it shares the same syntax as its English translation.
[inaudible] he drinks coffee Han is the third person singular personal pronoun.
Swedish has a system of personal pronouns, similar to that of English,
with a couple of differences. There are second person plural pronouns,
which are also used as formal second person, singular pronouns.
There are also two equivalents of it in English,
one for common gender den and one for nutrient death.
And there is also a controversial gender neutral pronoun hen.
This is not a pronoun that arose naturally in Swedish,
but it was constructed in order to replace the use of masculine pronouns in
contexts. When you are not specifically referring to a man or a woman, you know,
in English, I might use he or she in such a context.
Some people accept this pronoun at others rejected.
It isn't widely used in speech, but it's sometimes used in writing and on.
TV. [inaudible] does he drink coffee jar? The yard hub?
Yes, he does.
As you can see from this question in Swedish,
it's very simple to form a yes or no question.
You simply move to the verb to the front.
Took the sentence [inaudible].
Does he drink beer? Uh, is a cognitive, the English word ale.
No.
He doesn't the most common way to answer. Yes or no.
Questions is to first say yaw or ne followed by death than a verb followed
by the pronoun than the negation marker intent. If it's negative.
In many cases, the verbiage.
Form of Jara, which means do for each.
Verb tents, there was only one form of the verb.
It doesn't change depending on who or how many people are speaking.
So in the present tense it's.
Yeah, I do do yard. You do how many yard.
He does, et cetera. In the past tense it's [inaudible].
Do what you would, that you did, honey. You would, that he.
Did et cetera. In the future. It's.
[Inaudible] I will do discuss Jara. You will do [inaudible].
He will do et cetera.
Obviously this makes verbs easier to use than in many other languages.
[Inaudible].
I've never been to Norway word for word it's. I have never been in Norway.
This is almost word for word. The same as the English sentence,
except that he translates as in,
rather than to this sentence features the present perfect,
which is formed in a similar way to its English equivalent.
Notice that I said similar, not the same here. We have the auxiliary verb,
the present form of the verb hall, which means half over here,
we have a form of the verb, Vara, meaning beat in English.
We use the past participle, but in Swedish,
it's a different form called the supine.
And there's a different past participle form for other uses notice also that the
adverb comes between the two.
But then why not buy preferred means.
Why? And there's a cognate of the archaic English word, wherefore,
which you may know from Romeo and Juliet, wherefore art thou Romeo,
which doesn't mean where are you Romeo? Like most people think it does.
It means why are you Romeo? As in, why can't you be from a different family?
But I digress.
[Inaudible] in order. Yeah. And its value.
It's more expensive in Norway than in Sweden.
Word for word it's beer is more expensive in Norway than in Sweden.
It almost translates directly into English,
except for the way the comparative is expressed in English.
There are two comparative forms first with the ER suffix.
And second with more before the adjective with most two syllable adjectives and
all adjectives with three or more syllables in Swedish,
it's similar with single syllable adjectives,
taking the suffix audit and adjectives with two or more syllables being
proceeded by me. In this case,
the English word expensive has three syllables.
So it uses more while the Swedish word has only one syllable.
So it takes the audit ending. One more thing to note here is the verb.
Add it is the present tense conjugation of the verb. Vara,
meaning to be Varda is the infinitive form it developed from old Norse
VESA. Then it became Vera. Then it became Vara.
The English verb to be in all its different conjugations developed from two
different verbs,
old English bale and old English ways on which has cognate with the Swedish.
Word. [inaudible] may alt superlatives
[inaudible].
It's the biggest city in Sweden word-for-word it's,
which is Sweden's biggest city. Here.
We have the question word [inaudible] meaning,
which next we see [inaudible]. As I mentioned earlier,
Swedish used to have four cases, but now it only has two,
the nominative and the genitive,
which is shown with an S at the end of the now similar to how apostrophe S is
used in English to show possession.
Next [inaudible] is the super lucrative form of [inaudible], which means big,
just like Swedish has comparative forms that partly resemble the English ones.
In this case, it stowed it bigger.
It also has a superlative form that partly resembles the English.
One star is like the S ending in English,
but this one might not be the best example,
come to think of it because it's irregular most single syllable adjectives take
the ending us, or I stay like.
Do your.
Most expensive.
The form with the E at the end Asti is used when the adjective is definite,
particularly when proceeded by a definite article or genitive pronoun.
Multi-syllable adjectives from the Superleague when messed comes before them
like English, most, most intelligent would.
Be missed in the ligament. The.
Rules about single syllable words and multi-syllable words are not 100%.
In fact, this word could also be set with asked rather than messed,
but the rule is generally true.
So that is the stop stop cone.
The biggest city in Sweden is Stockholm word for word Sweden's biggest city is
Stockholm.
You have the body until it gets to some Stockholm.
Gotham, Berg isn't as big as Stockholm word for word it's Gotham.
Berg is not like big as Stockholm.
Comparisons of equality are formed in Swedish by using plus an
adjective followed by some literally equal adjective.
As Lyrica is a cognate of English like in its use as an adverb.
Do a little [inaudible].
You are as tall as Ella word for word, you are equally tall as Ella,
you may be getting the sense that Swedish has quite similar to English in its
grammar. And to some extent in its Germanic vocabulary,
English speaking learners of Swedish are often struck by just how similar the
two are and by how intuitive Swedish is for them.
The bigger challenges in learning Swedish seem to lie in the pronunciation and
the early stages and in getting used to dialectal variation and different
accents in the later stages.
But all in all people who learn Swedish overwhelmingly enjoy the process and
their efforts are well rewarded.
The question of the day for speakers of Swedish.
To what extent would you say that you speak standard Swedish?
And to what extent do you use your local dialect and to people who have studied
Swedish? What has your experience been like?
What have you found easy and what have you found challenging?
You're excited to learn more Swedish,
then click the link in the description to visit Swedish pod one Oh one or visit
Lang focused.com/swedish. Oh God.
It's one of the most extensive Swedish courses I've ever seen with literally
hundreds of lessons for learners of any level and the lessons get progressively
more challenging as your level improves as the name suggests they're podcast
based lessons,
which is great for people who like to learn using audio materials and for people
who want to learn on the go these days,
I try to focus much more on audio materials than I used to so that I can repeat
new words and phrases to improve my pronunciation. And at a more advanced level,
I shadow entire dialogues or monologues,
but pod one Oh one courses offer more than just audio lessons.
They have lots of video lessons,
as well as downloadable books and PDF materials so that you can get visual input
and explanations of all the language introduced in the lessons.
They also have audio recordings of the individual words and phrases.
So you can review them individually and you can create vocabulary flashcards
that you spaced repetitions to help you memorize the words more easily.
They also offer quizzes to help you review the lessons,
word lists of the most commonly used words and other features.
Now the biggest problem most learners seem to have with innovative language
courses is that the lessons are short.
So they make the mistake of breezing through them too quickly and moving onto
the next lesson.
But I really recommend that you slow down and you practice what you learn in
each lesson before moving onto the next one.
You can listen to the lesson multiple times, review the lesson,
transcript and notes,
use the flashcards and test yourself either by yourself or using the systems
built in quizzes. That's where the real learning takes place.
When you reinforce and review what you've learned,
I've never learned a language using only innovative language courses,
but I'm a member of several of their sites.
And I regularly use them as part of my study. Lots of content is free,
including all new lessons, which are free for the first couple of weeks.
And then if you want to access all the content,
you can upgrade to a paid account.
I really recommend you check out innovative languages courses,
whether for Swedish or one of the other 33 languages,
they offer click the link in the description to get a free lifetime account.
I also want to give a big shout out to all the Lang focus, Patrion supporters,
especially the top tier patrons whose names are on the screen. Check out
patrion.com/lang focus and check out the benefits of the various tiers and to
everyone. Thank you for watching and have a nice.